with the Euro 2016 football championship
well under way we decided to find our
own European champion six compact cars
are in the running they are all
manufactured in Europe some have also
been developed here each represents a
different country the German entry is
opals new fifth generation Astra powered
by a bi turbo high-tech diesel it's a
strong contender with its 118 kilowatt
engine it is the most powerful diesel in
its class the suspension is balanced and
the workmanship excellent
the fifth generation does not look much
different from its best-selling
predecessor a bit sportier and leaner
which looks good not only are the
materials high-quality there are plenty
of clever details and the seats are
surely the best available in this
segment the Astra sets high standards
but can the competitors outperform it
the ours is a Toyota made in England its
advanced hybrid powertrain makes it
another strong contender the electric
motor and gasoline engine work together
like a real team it is a very
eco-friendly energy efficient vehicle
fuel consumption is about four liters of
gasoline per 100 kilometers the driver
does not have much to do in this very
relaxing vehicle the 2016 ours has had a
bit of a facelift it also comes in the
station wagon version the interior has
been upgraded materials are better and
it has become west barton italy is out
to please the crowd with this new fiat
tipo the entry-level version sells for
an unbeatable price of twelve thousand
euros in germany the hatchback will soon
be joined by a five-door and a station
wagon version
italy is determined to score the
strategy is clear plenty of pretty car
for a very competitive price the seventy
kilowatt diesel version we tested with a
few extras cost just 20 grand in Germany
the exterior is sleek and elegant as
becomes a true Italian the interior is
spacious big enough for most families
but it's not exactly luxurious compared
to Fiats more expensive competitors
still you would not expect that given
the enticing price Spain has sent the
seat leon ecomotive out onto the pitch
can it keep up with just three cylinders
turbo and direct injection offset the
loss of a cylinder and then some the 85
kilowatt 200 Newton meter gasoline
engine delivers quite a punch had it as
fuel efficient at the same time
six liters per 100 kilometers is a
realistic number in every day traffic
the leon ecomotive is a smooth performer
the three cylinders don't vibrate nor do
they sound like a lawnmower even the
entry-level version offers a sporty firm
right the workmanship is impeccable the
model may be four years old but it does
not look at all outdated it may come as
a surprise given their names but the Kia
Cee'd and the Hyundai i30 are true
Europeans developed and manufactured
year they may share a common platform
but they are far from identical twins
they are also competing against each
other for our favor the Kia Cee'd has a
lien somewhat sporty look the big round
I'd instrument panel looks friendly with
black and grey make an elegant combo to
play forward it is equipped with a 100
kilowatt diesel engine and 6-speed
manual transmission it is a match for
any in the class
the Hyundai i30 has a more restrained
and sober look than the Kia the interior
is ergonomic and well put together but
perhaps a little over modest but Hyundai
gets extra points for all his extras
that come as standard it is also a bit
cheaper than the Kia performance-wise
there is little to choose between the
one is built in the Czech Republic the
other in Slovakia that's why Kia and
Hyundai can compete in our championship
if these cars were soccer stars they
would be considered dribbling champions
it's hard to really differentiate
between them they all have electronic
stability control all are comfortable to
drive all have a slight tendency to
oversteer which is typical of compact
cars only the sea otters out for its
more sporty nature without stability
control the rear would even veer out
slightly in a curve the competitors are
almost evenly matched all six compact
cars are strong contenders can a
championship and in a draw among all the
competitors if you want to buy one you
might have to just trust your taste and
see how much money you want to spend in
terms of regular classic football the
Opel Astra would win it's a true
all-rounder covering all the bases there
are no weak spots on the other hand
since the emissions scandal broke people
have become very wary of diesels in
general
the 2016 Toyota Auris represents the
future of the sport with its hybrid
powertrain the sea at Lyon is heading in
the right direction with its rather
special three-cylinder engine powered by
gasoline not diesel the Fiat tipo is a
great performer to be had for a
surprisingly low transfer fee the other
versions about to be released will only
make it more appealing the Kia and
Hyundai have come a long way elegant
Europeans advanced technology a match
for any rival Europe can play great
football Europe can also build great
cars